welcome to waters world I'm Jesse waters
liberal humiliation that is the subject
of tonight's waters words in political
warfare one of the goals is to make your
opponent look bad
sometimes your opponents do that to
themselves and that is what happened to
the left this week exhibit one Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer delivered the
Democrat response to president Trump's
oval office address on the border crisis
40 million viewers tuned in to see Nancy
and Chuck after the president standing
awkwardly together at the podium just 1
podium Americans were more amused by
their presentation than informed and the
duo got roasted hard on social media
here are some of the best memes American
Gothic anyone how about the twins from
the shining super villains there I think
that's the Joker in Batman and speaking
of super villains how about this I see
Pelosi went with the dr. evil outfit who
wore it better and many saw Nancy and
Chuck as parents we're not mad or just
disappointed
and my favorite Face Swap terrifying as
Greg Gutfeld said the other day on the 5
their response should have been followed
by quote unquote
paid for by Donald Trump for president
exhibit 2 another political opponent of
the president CNN White House
correspondent Jim Acosta went down to
McAllen Texas on the US Mexican border
Acosta doesn't want a wall and doesn't
believe that there is any crisis at the
border but he posted a video that
destroyed his own argument here are some
of the steel slats that the president's
been talking about right here as you can
see yes you can't see through these
slats to the other side of the us-mexico
border but as we're walking along here
we're not seeing any kind of imminent
danger there are no migrants trying to
rush toward this fence here in the
McAllen Texas area as a matter of fact
there are some other businesses behind
me along this highway there's a gas
station Burger King and
but no sign of the national emergency
that the president has been talking
about as a matter of fact it's pretty
tranquil down here hey Jim perhaps it's
tranquil because there's a border fence
migrants aren't rushing towards the
fence because there's a fence the
illegals cross where there's no fence
Jim Acosta working for President Trump
or CNN sometimes it's hard to tell what
an embarrassment exhibit three potential
Democrat presidential candidate bado
O'Rourke a sensation on social media
likes to bring voters into his world
usually he livestreams himself cooking
steak in the kitchen things like that
but bado took it a step too far this
week so I'm here at the dentist and
we're going to continue our series on
the people of the border I'm here with
Diana my dental hygienic Diana's gonna
tell us a little bit about growing up in
all this pain oh hopefully you don't
have a colonoscopy anytime soon
sometimes more is less sometimes less is
more so there you have it Democrats
humiliating themselves and Republicans
didn't even have to lift a finger
I wish politics could always be this
easy